Hey, this is really funny.
Donald Trump's lawyer, I guess I don't know
if he's still his lawyer.
Rudy Giuliani appeared yesterday morning on
Fox News propaganda show.
Fox and Friends, this was ahead of the first
presidential debate and Rudy Giuliani blurted
out this rambling conspiracy about Joe Biden
having dementia.
And as he did at the looks on the faces of
the Fox and Friends hosts, are they look like
they're sick to their stomachs.
It's kind of like a bizarre stream of consciousness.
Take a look at this first part from Rudy Giuliani.
The man has dementia.
There's no doubt about it.
I've talked to doctors.
I've had them look at a hundred different
tapes of his five years ago.
And today, the Biden people say he's fine.
He can't recite the Pledge of Allegiance.
And he's fine.
He's been.
He was in the Senate for a hundred and sixty
years.
I mean, so this is already weird because Rudy
says Biden can't recite the Pledge of Allegiance.
It's Trump who has visibly struggled to recite
the Pledge of Allegiance and the national
anthem.
And Biden's been in the Senate 160 years.
Rudy is making no sense whatsoever here.
And OK, the Fox and Friends crew is starting
to look a little bit concerned.
But Rudy is not slowing down.
He keeps it going.
He can't do the prologs.
To the contrary to the Constitution, United
States Declaration of Independence, any of
them.
He can't do numbers.
Wow.
Are the numbers screwed up?
He actually displays symptoms.
That, too, gerontologists told me, are classic
symptoms of middle level dementia.
It's so weird because this has turned into
the projection campaign.
Everything that Rudy Giuliani is expressing
is this suppose is everything Rudy is saying
as a supposed concern about Biden is actually
something that we're worried about with Trump.
Actual mental health and neurology professionals
have been sounding the alarm about Donald
Trump for years.
And Rudy Giuliani is trying to apply all of
those criticisms to Joe Biden.
Let's continue.
Well, that's when he does that.
I pledge allegiance to the United States.
I think I've done that twice.
That's right.
That's that's a classic symptom.
And the DSM five, it's the fifth symptom of
dementia.
He's got he's got he's got eight of the 10.
Look, that isn't the debate.
He'll if he can get through it.
I think the president is quite right to say
maybe he's taken Adderall or a some kind of
attention deficit disorder.
So, you know, then with the Adderall, once
again, it's Donald Trump who appears to very
clearly have upper and downer days.
And it's Donald Trump who the world speculates
is taking some kind of uppers.
Could be Adderall, could be abusing allergy
pills, according to Michael Cohen, could be
abusing nasal decongestants, et cetera.
It's it's.
Do they not see this?
Do they not realize every allegation that
Donald Trump, rather, that Rudy Giuliani is
making about Joe Biden has been applied seriously
to Donald Trump?
Now, it gets so bad that Fox and Friends hosts
try to interfere a little bit.
They try to help out Rudy Giuliani.
But Rudy can't be stopped.
He just keeps going.
A some kind of attention deficit disorder.
And that's why the president wants to do a
drug test for you know, none of us are talking.
This is just that's your opinion.
So it will be interesting to see what happens
tonight.
No, it's not.
No, it's not just my opinion.
It's the opinion of a number of doctors I've
actually interviewed.
Right.
We could say we're talking to the Supreme
Court, cause that's gonna be a topic tonight
at the debate, of course.
What do we.
And you hear Brian kill me.
They're saying we can stay away from this
topic.
And there is just so much projection.
Consider the absurdity of Rudy Giuliani rambling
incoherently through his claims that someone
else has cognitive issues.
It's really incredible.
Rudy mentions 10 dementia symptoms in the
DSM five.
DSM five actually replaces the term dementia
with major neurocognitive disorder and mild
neurocognitive disorder.
And it doesn't list 10 symptoms.
I mean, everything Rudy Giuliani saying here
is completely backwards.
Beyond the bigger picture, that these really
are allegations that have been credibly made
about Trump, which have not been answered.
It's actually tragic in a way.
I was never like a big Rudy guy, but especially
after 9/11, Rudy Giuliani was truly he wasn't
a universally loved.
But in a polarized America, after 9/11, Rudy
was as close to universally loved as you could
imagine.
And then, B, he became, you know, mayor 9/11,
noun verb, 9/11 became Rudy Giuliani's way
of speaking.
He then jumped in with Trump completely.
And now he has sort of become it's almost
like he's the hatchet kook who has to go around
saying the things Trump would love to be saying,
but finds himself stopping short of Rudy Giuliani's
the Gaulois, a guy out there doing it, just
an irrelevant crackpot, making no sense whatsoever.
In a way, it's sad what's happened to Rudy
Giuliani.
And meanwhile, at a recent rally, Donald Trump
said Rudy should really run for mayor of New
York again.
I have a hard time imagining Rudy could win
at this point.
Tell me if you disagree.
We'll have more coverage of all of the shenanigans
surrounding the first presidential debate
on the show's Instagram page.
You can find it
at The David Pakman Show
on Instagram,